are the linear equations below dependent
or independent and they give us two
equations right over here a system of
equations and so just as a little bit of
review let's think about the different
types of relationships between lines we
can have when we're dealing with two
variables so we're going to be dealing
with two dimensions so let me draw
myself some some coordinate axes right
over here some coordinate planes so
let's call this the x-axis let's call
this the y-axis and let me copy and
paste this since I'm gonna drew three
different scenarios so let me copy and
then let me paste it so that's another
scenario right over there let me just go
a little bit over to the left and then
let me throw in the third scenario right
over there so when you're dealing with
two lines there's a couple of different
ways that you can think about it you
could have two separate lines that do
intersect so you could have a line that
looks like that and a line that looks
like that a line that has a different
slope and they definitely do intersect
you could have two lines you could have
two independent or I won't use that word
just yet cuz I'll explain what it means
you could have two lines that are not
the same line so but they don't
intersect they have the same slope with
different y intercepts so they are
parallel to each other these are
parallel lines or you could have the two
lines or actually end up being the same
exact line and I'll do that by coloring
it right on the same point so this is
the same line so this is the same line
so these are lines with different slopes
that intersect these are lines with the
same slope where they there are two
different lines they have different
y-intercepts
these are two lines with the same slope
and the same y intercept they're
essentially the same line so when we
think about lines like this and these
lines were set represent the solution
set of equations the first two right
over here where we have two separate
lines they're not the same line we call
these two separate equations as being
dependent or these two line I'm sorry we
call these two separate equations as
being independent they're not dependent
on each other these two are the same
thing these two our dependence let me
clarify this this is in the pen
in dependent independent and this is
independent independent right over here
if you have two different lines then
you're talking about independent
equations if you have the same line then
you're talking about a dependent you're
talking about two dependent equations
they are essentially the exact they
represent the exact same line and this
is when you refer to when you when you
refer to the equations themselves now in
a kind of related notion is when you
look at the system as a whole and you
think about how many solutions the
system has so this is when you think
about the equations it could be
independent or dependent dependent is
the same line when you think about when
you think about the system as a whole
you think about how many solutions it
has and if it has no solutions you call
it inconsistent and so this is the only
one that has no solutions these lines
never never intersect so this is
inconsistent inconsistent while these
this one over here has exactly one
solution this is consistent consistent
and this one over here actually has an
infinite number of solutions but it's
still consistent you have at least one
consistent you have at least one
solution now in this example they're
asking us whether the equations are
dependent or independent so you look at
this classification up over here so if
they're just two separate if they can be
represented by two separate lines
they're independent if they're the exact
same line they are dependent so let's
figure them out and the best way to
figure them out is to put them in the
exact same form the second equation here
is already in MX plus B form let's put
this top equation in MX plus B form so
we have 4x plus 2y is equal to 16 let's
subtract 4x from both sides to get rid
of the X's on the left-hand side so
let's subtract 4x from both sides on the
left-hand side you're left with 2y on
the right-hand side you're left with
negative 4x plus 16 now we can divide
both sides of this equation by 2 by 2 so
we're going to divide all the terms by 2
and we're left with Y is equal to
negative 2x
negative 2x plus 8 so when we put this
first equation in MX plus B form we
actually got the exact same thing as
this second equation right over here
that these simplify to the exact same
thing so these are actually the exact
same line they both have the exact same
slope and they both have the exact same
y-intercept same slope same y-intercept
so they are the same lines these
equations right over here are dependent